[Music]
going hey now good morning
hey now hey I'm in the mood to sell you
know I really like I like I loved him
but I like Adam Bartha oh yeah Adam
Barta is tan mom's writing partner in
his I love it too i legend this is the
part of that song I love is him I'm free
she's free to be Patricia Murray you see
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
musical chairs used to keep stopping I
start dancing
JD what's going on with you and
Rappaport Michael Rapaport the actor I
faced in this past week in fantasy
football and you know how he is whenever
he likes to be very you know he tries it
getting there in your head a little bit
Gary you [ __ ] I got a secret weapon now
I want to take this [ __ ] Jason Kaplan
okay I want to zip tie him I want to
[ __ ] them and then I want to cook up
wake up [ __ ]
wake up will Murray hit him with two hi
I'm gonna ruin him and I'm gonna [ __ ]
his face I'm saying like I'm gonna [ __ ]
his face during fantasy football oh so
then he started calling you at home or
was he calling you here voicemails like
that when I wouldn't pick it up does it
bother you that he calls no he's trying
to do she's like I'm gonna [ __ ] you in
the ass you know he gets crazy I try to
say stuff backed all the Nagus all weird
it out what do you mean like I say
sounds like are you ready [ __ ] or
whatever I go yeah yeah bend me over or
something like that and he doesn't want
his proposal accepted he wants you to be
grossed out let me hear this JD this is
Michael Rapaport Sunday morning you know
what that means right it's time for
[ __ ] I've been [ __ ] every single
person in this league i lapped fault
big fat Jason Kaplan I beat him so bad I
ran around the track
[ __ ] them from behind mmm kept going
that's called lapped [ __ ] but he's
really into fantasy football then he
gets annoyed with the JD that he hasn't
called him back no JD takes just dick
have you cut your [ __ ] hair yet call
me the [ __ ] back you're not that [ __ ]
important have you ever thought about
getting into the stringent you know I
mean like for oily skin you [ __ ] and it
goes up man he spends all Sunday dude
why would you call him back
call me back so I can give you skin care
tip like a stringent
with demean you are you kind of honored
in a way JD when you think about like
kind of but this is like a guy who's
been in major films calling you and
wants to [ __ ] you in your ass higher
learning then he was great he was yeah
it's kind of cool like yeah it was the
man show and you know I would go through
and make edit notes on all the tape so I
get all the bits and there was one bit
they shot I think it was like household
hints with adult film stars and they
shot with like jenna jameson or
something like that right and I get this
long real and it's very sexual and I
don't know I'm probably in my late 20s
at the time I'm pretty sexed up and I
start watching it and at that time my
imagination still worked I was still
able to masturbate with my eyes closed
so now I start watching this and I start
masturbating I'm in my office
masturbating to yourself no no no I
wasn't in this bit it was like a
separate thing I wasn't actually there
so I'm masturbating in my office I and
then I closed my eyes and the next thing
I hear is my ex-wife Gina's voice going
are you masturbating and I open my eyes
and the next choice is Adam Carolla at
the hardware store she caught you
masturbating to Adam Carolla Adam
Carolla do you do you bother even
explaining to her that look I was it's
even worse no I was masturbating to the
beautiful women on this I tried to do
that but she was too busy running to go
call all her friends to let them know
that I she'd caught me masturbating Oh
God do you see the humor and at that
time are you like oh my god no it was it
was immediately
Fred might know this is jethro tull in
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame that's
ridiculous
Aqualung the album one of the greatest
albums ever written
[ __ ] these guys yeah they've been
eligible since 93 like this guy made the
flute Cole I mean just getting late with
a flute is worth getting into the Hall
of Fame you know like if I was inducting
I'd be like this [ __ ] guy he got laid
with a flute well do you know they're
kind of disrespected in 1989 they won a
Grammy yeah but the record company
decided not to even fly them over they
just assumed they wouldn't win probably
because he had a flute whoo you Casey
Kasem and yeah so what so they won heavy
metal of course they should don't listen
man I love how to even start out with
like a piano thing you think you're
listening to some concerto you figure
out the Simona Dennis theme concert and
then all of a sudden here we go right
here WN bc
oh my god that's so amazing yes well let
me tell you who is nominated Dilla's
here Radiohead ah three I relate to this
I got a perfect body
yeah I got a perfect soul Def Leppard Oh
Def Leppard
[Music]
I love that the one-armed drummer one
came bad yeah awesome just shows you you
don't need two hands for a drumming I
was rated two hands over ad is awesome
Simon concert do it Stevie Nicks
now you're talking there's a woman who
deserves to be in the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame solo is just absolutely just for
this song Joe Walsh was [ __ ] yeah
choices she's wild just like the white
wing dove is in zoo baby baby
make sure you got UW up you see bumper
sticker like you forgot to play it even
though [ __ ] that we would've been fired
me
[Music]
I would vote for them a by Devo I dig
the outfit in the attitude but I don't
know before jethro tull do you been yeah
poor Ian Anderson sitting and fishing in
England somewhere Kraftwerk Oh with the
bomb bomb bomb at the Autobahn catch
them oh my god these [ __ ]
there's a Hitler's favorite band crap
[Music]
these guys were out there man remember
the album cover like this yeah
trans europe express alright enough with
this soon it's such nonsense yeah that's
what jethro tull thing I can't even
imagine what JT's like with his wife
yeah yeah does she talk yeah isn't she
like what the [ __ ] is he saying no no no
they really how would they really love
each other yeah I don't know JD and his
wife are definitely the most
touchy-feely of our Iliad still that way
oh yeah would you say that Ron yeah yeah
like she's rubbing his head and like
touching his titties to put his arm
around holding hands lead him in yeah
come here JD yep take my hand wow I I
didn't know she was so physical with him
you must like that JD I'm a sucker for
that give me your key Howard she's also
very physically fit and I'm almost sure
she could take him really yeah you think
oh great I see her in the gym with like
lifting big weights really she could
totally I think she could take JD she
can just down him know in a wrestling
match he's gone dead I mean she runs she
have a really good body she's a great
shape yeah she runs a lot she's Redmond
she has a running body yeah she does you
know those running body
the sweat and squirt
well JD lost an arm wrestling match to
Robin I know
[Laughter]
JD do you think you could take your wife
in a wrestling match the world's most
famous pimp has died Dennis HOF HOF was
72 and most people knew him from either
our show or the HBO documentary series
cathouse yes and cathouse I suppose you
would say it followed the lives of
Dennis and the women at his brothel
his most famous brothel was called the
bunny ranch and he also owns six other
legal brothels which I didn't know
either but he died not at the bunny
ranch but at the love ranch south yeah
another brothel
we had Dennis on the show for the first
time in 2000 and the guy clearly loved
his work by the way this is Dennis HOF
who is the I you the head of the bunny
ranch for the pit master general as you
point out that doesn't like by the way I
think one of the most gracious and
memorable things he did in his lifetime
in terms of the Stern Show he is the guy
who helped one of our legends finally
lose his virginity and of course I'm
referring to Eric the actor yes Eric
lost his virginity at the bunnyranch
loved it there
Dennis invited him out there paid for a
visit a beautiful girl named hailey had
sex with Eric the actor Eric was
miserable about everything in his life
but I gotta tell you in this clip I
don't think I ever heard Eric so upbeat
she gets me out of bed
I'm completely hard to put the condom on
continues to give me a [ __ ] and stuff
and then eventually I think after one
[ __ ] we end up having sex for the
first time we mean after one [ __ ] you
completed you blew your load into the
rubber with the [ __ ] yeah let's make
a wish
make a sick wish thank God for Dennis
HOF and I got it
Eric was never going to have
no if you remember he even set up a
threesome for Eric on the same trip and
Eric really wanted to make sure we knew
about that over me you didn't even hear
me say and add one oh you had two at the
same time and of course the other voice
in there was the late Johnny fraud both
God loved both those guys
and you know I have certainly weird
feelings about anybody who pimps for a
living but getting Eric laid I mean that
was kind of gracious and then he got
somebody else laid Dennis had a
connection to the woman JD lost his
virginity to if you remember JD was a
virgin until he was 26 JD JD because of
the show he finally had sex with a girl
he met on myspace named Courtney well
how did Dennis have a connection to that
and is called into the show right
afterward and said he dated her too oh
you're kidding no oh
Courtney's cool Courtney and I have been
friends for a while she's a great lover
right I think this guy needs to get a
better education so we can afford a
chick like this because he's had some
big-time booty now where does he go from
here
is Dennis a former boyfriend of yours
Courtney what does that mean I mean
you're a great lover how would even
notice you know if you're a great lover
right I did sleep with Bennet oh you did
JD did that KD did you realize you and
Dennis we're Eskimo brothers that term
right judge Cavanaugh taught me that
term Eskimo brothers it was weird too
because Courtney was trying to be
diplomatic at first but eventually
admitted that Dennis was a much better
lover than JD is now right JD Dennis you
did help a lot of people get laid and I
guess that's an important calling in
life
did you see Bryant got like a choker oh
you gotta see that yeah he got his whole
arm with the Joker from Batman
Bryant get in here really yeah he's got
a plan or villains going up his arm
oh there's different uh-huh she'll Robin
you're Joker
he has tattoo categories for his arms
like what this is the villain oh my god
tell me that it's awful
it's a big giant watch of a joker yeah I
guess you need glasses then I mean
that's it this is you it could be Jesus
with all those robes I mean you have
Joker on your arms yeah and I've got
bizarro on my upper arm see don't
bizarre oh yeah yeah that's a right arm
what's the left arm representing the
left arm Blackbeard supplying here in
the the anarchy symbol underneath here
oh my god that's very satanic and what
does that represent for that arm it's
it's basically just you know [ __ ] the
laws and [ __ ] these people I'm gonna do
my own thing really yeah [ __ ] the law
there's certain people in this country
yeah if you're rich enough or you're a
politician you're connected enough the
laws don't really apply to you but
aren't you mr. citizen's arrest he's
gonna run for government yeah yeah well
that's on his other on
[Laughter]
Jimmy and Molly as you know are
America's Sweethearts well you thrilled
to see Ronnie Jimmy's face around Ronnie
makes me the happiest I said to Molly
this morning as we were getting ready I
said are you excited to see Ronnie it
did make Jim mixture mr. happy I'm more
excited to see JD and I was very happy
to see Robin you indicate that that I
don't think this is a secret that you
and JD direct message to each other
everyone yeah I love JD he's wonderful
he's better on texting than he is on
yeah person he does have a terrible
handshake I don't know if you guys I've
ever it's like you can feel how many
times he's jerked off when he has any
muscle I love you JD what did he shake
your hand time who's years ago we'll see
if he's improved his handshake I'll go
do that now it's thanks mostly all right
great
[Music]
I saw you this morning you look way fan
well I was also detoxing this week with
Judith yes what goes on where do you do
it
we coffee intimate house how do you
coffee enema you should enjoy this
toilet with your enema spray you didn't
get any like coffee did you clean the
toilet and stuff no it was all very neat
that's so gross like wait is it so who
makes the coffee
Judith made the coffee so she brewed
coffee and then you put it in an enema
bag and shoot it here and you went into
your room nude and you stick a thing in
your [ __ ]
and how far in do you get this thing
into your ass oh my god this is not
right you don't need seven or eight
inches in your [ __ ] you could take
seven or eight inches
[Music]
what was that weird thing going on
between you and Ronnie yesterday Gary
what happened you got on the wrap-up
show we're talking about the dinner we
went to level with JD and John and
Ronnie and I just said that I thought
ronnie was acting a little weird that
night it was almost like we were still
on the air and just kind of surprising
to me because I was looking at talk to
Ronnie but I think he was being it was
that he was very well enough that well
all I know is he was listening to that
and he was like I don't know what Gary's
talking about Ronnie was on fire in the
car he was like so he got riled up
because of what Gary said Ronnie what
was it we learned yesterday that you
made Gary uncle I didn't misunderstand
anything I heard exactly what he said
what do you say he said that I thought I
kind of made him uncomfortable like he
wasn't wanted there I love your accent
but what to do when we are to dinner I
felt strange with Ronnie it didn't feel
comfortable in other words he wasn't
talking to you no I felt like he was
kind of like just kind of performing
well I apologized to for making
uncomfortable Wow when he walked back
from the wrap-up show he said I'm really
sorry for making you uncomfortable I
know what he did was it busted my balls
just fine so you don't want to go out
with them anymore no I do yeah we're
gonna go out go to his birthday party at
the Jazz birthday party the biggest
problem for me is yeah you might drop
dead don't have a birthday yeah it got
moved from a Friday to a Saturday night
and I bought the tickets and didn't
mention to Mary so I told her about it
last night and she just cuz I [ __ ]
hate jazz why don't you all just admit
you [ __ ] hate jazz and go somewhere
fun why are you torturing yourselves I
actually thought to some Brandon's idea
what he's an idiot why are you listening
to him I'm not listening to me it
doesn't [ __ ] would you like to put
yourself through that because Steve
Steve what kind of cool yeah no it's
cool
Chet you guys take orders from Steve
Brandon I'm not taking orders do
something fun I'm gonna take it orders
he said we're all going would you like
to join us
yeah
let me set it up hey Steve why would you
why would you suggest the jazz club
nobody really likes jazz not in this
group I hear what you're saying yeah why
would you Blake if I have one night free
I'm not gonna go somewhere where I kind
of don't like it Ronnie and I hang a lot
during the mornings while we're waiting
for the guests Ronnie and I spend a lot
of time together nowadays it was a weird
day where I was listening to piano music
in the green room and Ronnie came in and
was like you like this stuff and I was
like yeah you like this stuff and he was
like I've been to jazz cuz did you
decide who should go to Ronnie party
there you left a lot of people I said I
would love to do this with you I know
your birthday is coming up right I don't
want to make this a thing about me well
you're glad would you like to do this
and he said yes then why did you leave a
lot of people are feeling left out of
this group sorry what are you gonna do I
know I know one person who a Richard I
think Richard feels I would blow you to
be left out of that Jon Gary JD who
usually hang out with Ronnie and said I
am perfectly happy to go with just
Ronnie and I and we'll find a night to
do it if you guys would like to do this
you really enjoy hanging out with Ronnie
for this I do Wow
and also I said and I would love if we
could keep this to at least going to it
before it gets to on air but that cats
out of the bag
and now you will goof on us for what is
just a cool fun night of going out Steve
Brendon oh and Ronnie hanging out sounds
like maybe the most horrible thing I've
ever heard of why it just sounds like a
nightmare
sound cool cool hang Gary you little
leave that group they don't want you
there anyway I'm kind of getting mad
our Stern you see I'm Mike Rappaport I
got the skills I got the class and when
those guys lose their butts are bruised
or when I [ __ ] them up in math